If you were to look outside the entry
place for a building, you may see these
steel or concrete barriers. These are
barricades or ballards that are designed
to prevent access, especially access by
other vehicles through that particular
area. This is also a good way to channel
people through a specific point. So, you
can have people still walk through those
barriers, but you've effectively now
prevented any larger vehicle from
getting through that particular area.
This means we can dedicate certain areas
to only be for pedestrians and not have
to worry about any other vehicle being
in the area, which of course is much
safer. And you may find different types
of ballards or barricades depending on
the environment that you're working
with. In some environments, you might
have these very large concrete round
barriers that are installed. Or you may
find there is water around a building so
that you have a canal or a moat to
create a natural barrier.
If you've ever visited a data center,
you may find that you're walking into a
small locked room that is first asking
you for your identification and your
justification for entering the building.
This intermediate area between the
outside world and the inside part of the
data center is referred to as an access
control vestibule. And there are
different types of vestibules depending
on the environment you're working with.
For example, it may be that all of the
doors of this access control vestibule
are unlocked, but when you open one of
those doors, all of the other doors lock
themselves to prevent any access through
the system. This means that only one
person or one group of people can be
moved through that vestibule at any
particular time. Other security controls
might have all of the doors normally
locked and when you unlock one of the
doors, perhaps with an access card, all
of the other doors remain locked. You're
not able to unlock those until this door
closes. And of course, there may just be
two doors in this particular area. One
to come in one side of the room and
another door to exit the other side of
the room. And when one door is open, the
other one remains locked. The idea
behind these vestibules is to know
exactly who is going in and out of a
protected area. And usually they are
some type of receptionist or security
guard who's checking the IDs and access
badges for everyone moving through that
area. Here's a view from outside one of
these access control vestibules. You can
see there is an access card reader on
the outside that gets you access to the
inside of this room. You can then check
in with the reception area, provide some
identification, and they'll unlock the
door to allow you access to the rest of
the
facility. These days, we don't tend to
use physical keys to gain access to a
room. Instead, the process is all
electronic, commonly using our access
card to be able to swipe or gain access
using one of these access card readers.
Although you may still run into the
older style magnetic reader, most of the
readers these days are RFID or NFC. That
way, you're able to integrate it into
the badge and simply move it close to
the reader to be able to activate. These
badge readers often provide access to
locked areas, but you can also use these
to clock in or clock out, and sometimes
they're also integrated into the rounds
that are done by your security team. If
you were to carefully cut your access
card in half to see what was inside,
you'd probably see something like this.
We have a key next to this to show you
what size this happens to be. And you
can see if you look very closely, there
is an RFID chip right in the middle and
it is connected to an antenna that wraps
around the inside of the card.
Video monitoring has become very popular
and very economical in recent years and
many organizations will have some type
of video monitoring or CCTV which stands
for closed circuit television. This
allows you to see what's happening in
many areas of your building or outside
of your building without having someone
physically located in that area. And our
modern cameras have become very
intelligent. They can identify different
types of vehicles. They can read license
tags and be able to provide you with
feedback based on what they are seeing.
An organization may have many of these
cameras deployed. They're allworked
together and all of that video signal
comes back to one central recording
station. Your cameras can use radio
reflection or infrared, especially at
night, to be able to see if anyone may
be in the area. And if it does detect
motion, it can identify and alarm that
on your console. This allows one person
to watch cameras that may be located
across the entire organization and be
able to monitor all of them from one
place. Getting an alarm or an alert from
these systems can be done in a number of
different ways. You could be using a
circuit-based alert system that will
identify when either a door is opened or
a door would be closed. This would then
send a signal back saying that there was
some type of activity with that
particular door. or you may have this
located on a window or a fence. So any
type of change or movement with anything
in that environment would send an alert
back to the security team. We might also
include sensors for motion detection.
That way if there's any type of
movement, even if we're not watching the
screen, we'll receive a notification
that something was moving in that
particular area. And in high security
environments, there may be a duress
button, perhaps a button underneath your
desk. And if someone feels that this is
an unsafe situation, they can push that
button to cause the alarm to
fire. There are many different ways to
lock and secure a door and then provide
access through that locked door. One of
the most common ways is using a
conventional lock and key. This is the
way that most of us will protect our
homes and it's something that requires a
physical key to be able to open that
lock. This works in conjunction with
things like a deadbolt to provide
additional security for that physical
lock. We might also use an electronic
lock like the one you see here where you
have to input a very specific personal
identification number to gain access
through that particular door. And as
we've already seen, there are tokenbased
door locks that will use the RFID chip
inside of your badge to allow you access
through a door. And in some high
security environments, you might be
using biometrics. So it might be
performing a fingerprint check or a
handprint or it's even scanning the
retina of your eye itself to prove that
you are really the person who needs
access. And it's not unusual to have
multiple factors of authentication
especially for highly secure
environments. So for instance, you might
scan your badge. You might then put in a
personal identification number and then
use a fingerprint to confirm your
identity. Even in very secure data
centers, it might be a good idea to use
locks on your cabinets to only allow
access to authorized personnel. In large
organizations, there might be multiple
groups that are accessing all of these
systems inside of a data center, and you
want to be sure that you're locking down
those areas for those particular groups.
To provide this level of security, we'll
often put all of our racks together side
by side so you can't access anything
inside the racks from those side panels.
We'll then add doors on the front and
the back with locks so that we can
prevent access to the equipment that's
inside. But of course, we still need to
cool all of that equipment. So, it's
very common to have holes on the bottom
and the top so that we can still have
cool air flow through the system. And
once you have everything installed, it
looks like this. You have all of these
racks that are now put side by side.
Some of these doors are glass, others
are perforated so that it will allow air
flow through the system while still
maintaining security. If you need access
to the equipment that's inside, you're
going to need the key so that you can
unlock these doors to gain
access. Many organizations will have a
person who's responsible for the
security of an area. That person is
often a security guard who's at the
reception area of a building. They might
also be patrolling around the building
as well. This is a person who can
receive your identification, evaluate
the identification, and then either
allow you access to the building or deny
you access. It's very common for
organizations to require every employee
to wear an ID badge. This will have a
picture and their name, and it's usually
held on a lanyard that's around their
neck. As a visitor, you may also be
given one of these badges. In some
environments, they'll even take your
picture and give you a temporary
version, but you need to make sure that
you're wearing that badge everywhere you
go in the building. And I've visited
some facilities where you need to
pre-register with the organization to
gain access. So when you arrive at the
building, the security guard will check
an access list that has a physical list
of names of people who are allowed into
the building during that day. If your
name's on the list, then it speeds the
process through and you can gain access
to the facility. This also provides an
audit trail. You're simply not allowing
someone to walk into the building and
walk out again. There is a timestamp and
a date of who visited the building,
where they went, and when they exited
the building.
Fences not only make good neighbors,
they also make good security for your
building. Most organizations will have
some type of perimeter around the
building that prevents access through
particular areas. These might be fences
that are transparent that you can see
through or they may be opaque and very
difficult to see what's on the other
side. The goal is to prevent anyone from
gaining access through that particular
area. So, most of these fences are
usually a heavy metal and are resistant
to any type of breaking. And as you can
tell, these fences are more than just a
few feet off the ground. They're high
enough to make it difficult for somebody
to gain access over the fence as well.
In extreme cases, you may also see razor
wire at the top to help prevent anyone
from gaining access over the fence.